Yes. If you are working in the UK
and you've got a visa,
in your case,
skill worker,
migrant in the UK,
you've got to leave and work in
accordance with the conditions of your leave to remain.
If you are in
breach of conditions of your leave to remain,
then you might not meet the stability requirement
or at a time of renewal or extension of your visa,
you may face difficulties.
Besides that,
if you're not in compliance
with the conditions of your visa,
then that would most likely be reflected
at level of HMRC,
at level of the Tax office.
And what happens is
your employer is supposed to be aware of these.
And if your employer is aware of this,
your employer
or your sponsor is duty bound to report this,
to notify the Home Affairs about what's happening.
And if your employer is not doing that,
then your employer sponsor lies
and is also at risk of revocation or suspension.
And if that happens,
obviously your visa would also be curtelled
most likely.
If your visa is curtelled,
you won't receive 60 days
during which you should decide what you wanna do,
whether you want to switch to a different visa category
or you want to leave the country.
In order to avoid a situation like this,
what you've got to do
is to comply with conditions of your visa.
You cannot comply with conditions of your visa
because things are beyond your control.
Then You have to quickly switch to a different category
or to a different sponsor.
That is a reality
and it is very difficult to get away from this.